again new actually burly at breakfast
the endurance swimmer Lewis Pugh has set
himself a challenge to swim where no
human has so far ever ventured a lake on
the Antarctic Ice Sheet the UN is patron
of the oceans or some a kilometer
through super glacial water to raise
awareness of the climate crisis and the
continuing threat to ice caps from
global warming delighted to say that
there is joins us now from Cape Town
hello to those thanks to joining us on
the program this morning last time I saw
you we were at the races I think at
Ascot now you're planning to swim in
freezing cold water what's all that
about thank you so much k yes I'm
heading down south to Antarctica to what
we call a super glacial lake so a super
a glacial lake is a lake which appears
on top of an ice cap scientists have now
found 65 thousand of these in East
Antarctica on the ice sheet it's a
manifestation of the climate emergency I
want to go down there do a swim there
and then go to two nations to Russia and
China to urge them to help protect this
area and international law 25 nations
have to agree to protect this area
they've all agreed except Russia and
China so I'm going to do the swim and
then straight off to Moscow and Beijing
to try to get your message across
haven't you two politicians are they
listening yes a lot of them are
listening but an awful lot of work needs
to be done you'll be aware that the
climate change negotiations which took
place in Madrid last week and a week
before to be honest they were very very
disappointing we now need action and we
need action very very quickly across the
board all nations and so it's gonna be a
very heavy lift for the United Kingdom
governments which will be hosting the
next climate change negotiations in
Glasgow at the end of 2020
the challenge that you're facing at the
start of next year there what's gonna be
the hardest part for you well the
training is gonna be hard the thing
about when you when you have swum in
cold water when you swim in really
really really cold water you'd never
ever forget it it's stays in your memory
I did a swim in the Arctic a few years
back and I saw will not forget that and
so now the training which are going to
be
in the Outer Hebrides that's a tough
stage where you have to spend a long
time in very very cold water comparing
myself but this one which I'm going to
do down in Antarctica how long are you
hopeful that the swim will take if all
goes according to plan it is a kilometer
I mean you can quite literally do that
in your sleep but not with these
sub-zero temperatures no I mean it
I pray it doesn't take any longer than
21 minutes 21 minutes doesn't sound like
a long time but when the water is about
zero degrees centigrade and when outside
the air temperature can be minus 30
degrees centigrade it is absolutely
freezing you know as soon as I dive into
their water it is it's a very very
dangerous environment I got to swim as
fast as I can as hard as I can
twenty-one minutes is a long time in
those conditions what made you think
that this was the next good challenge
for you the next big challenge for you
obviously you have a look at the map and
you think all work where can I go next
to best highlight the challenges face
[ __ ] facing our planet but why did you
choose this on I always look at when we
tried to decide which campaign we're
going to do we asked ourselves a very
very simple is it big enough to matter
is it small enough to win okay
and around Antarctica there are a number
of very very important areas which we
really need protecting between as I
mentioned 23 nations agreed to protect
these areas just to still need to
protect it I think that it's really
important and I do believe that China
and Russia presented with the right
evidence will agree to protect them and
if we do that we'll be creating a hugely
network of marine protected areas around
the southern ocean it's one of the most
important areas in the world if we get
that right that's a really good start to
2020 that you put in the paper wanted
looking for young guns to train with
polar swimmer no tea breaks with your
contact details there as well you're
looking for I'm looking I'm looking for
a number different things I'm looking
for somebody who can swim hard and fast
really get me training really really
hard I'm looking for somebody who's got
the right attitude the water in the
Outer Hebrides and the sea will be about
five degrees in the loss would be about
zero degrees but last the most important
somebody who's passionate about
protecting the environment that can help
me get in the right condition to do the
swim in Antarctica and then get to
Moscow and to Beijing okay it's good to
talk to you good luck hopefully we'll
speak to you again before you take on
the challenge but fern I thank you very
much indeed for joining us fingers
crossed thank you so much Kate thank you
this